Trump keeps going back to relitigate
2020 which a lot of people are saying we
don't want to hear about 2020 we want to
hear about 2024 Trump keeps returning to
this theme only a party that cheats that
elections would make it illegal to
question those elections that's the only
ones that would really make it
difficult
if you can challenge a rigged election
think of it we're not looking to do it
we want you know they don't go after the
people that rigged the election they go
after the people that want to find out
what the hell happened it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace now the Geniuses the
total Geniuses in the GOP Consulting and
chattering class they say that any
Republican nominee especially Trump if
he wants to win in 2024 it needs to move
on from issues like election Integrity
has to move on stop talking about the
last election oh quit going that doesn't
pull well in the suburbs they tell us I
don't know that is not going to happen